hello welcome to a new edition of
las vegas now in spanish health to
natalia maintained today we start with the
latest in the world of
entertainment from batman and adventure and that is that
their new collaboration is called volví and it
is sweeping the world of music
With this new hit, which is a mixture
of the batman trap and the
adventurous bachatera ballad, I think we are
feeling that I was back without type in
2005 when I came back, it ranks first
on several music charts,
including enapu music, you can see the
full video  on youtube and if you want and
if you are a maximus super fan of batman
and this state you can enjoy batman
and night at breaking world in the link
where the dj will liven up the night with the
artist's biggest hits
this event is for people over
18  years for more information visit
blooming bou dotcom
ok a music festival that if you
like music now in vi like me it
should move and I'm talking to you  do of
the lovers and friends festival with
performances by several
iconic artists such as usher ludacris baby bass
mina sky and much more lovers and friends
will take place in may next year but
tickets for that event are already on
sale for more information visit lovers
and friends fest dotcom
and for fans of
country music ribamar singing and the duo brooks
in so announced the final dates of
their residency on their backs together in
vegas or twitters together in vegas
rather the music residency with their most
successful in the city will take place from the 1st  to
december 15th tickets go on
sale this friday august 5th via
ticketmaster dotcom
well and before saying goodbye let me
introduce you to the magical world
vincent this is a town full of
christmas lights as you can see it will come
to our city for the first time  during
the end of the year holidays in change will
transform into las vegas boat because in
a winter wonderland from
nov 26  September to January 2 for more
information visit Sant Crist more
dotcom
well here I come to your edition of las
vegas nao in Spanish thank you very much for
your attention see you next week
natalia greets you bad sound
[Music]